the film messed me up like because the
client because it's what racism feels
like like that descent into rage that
that's I know that thank you both of you
phone book movies my questions for
Timothy I don't I don't ruin it for
everyone but I'm talking about the last
scene and you can take it as his
breakdown because of news
he just got from Oliver but also as a
breakdown from the OL experience he went
through and he stuff is winter whereas
the summer goes through in Italian he's
it's kind of floating through it so I
wanted your input on how you played it
and what emotion you've put in the last
scene yeah I think that's why I really
like the way you put it I've never
imagined it in the lens of a like a of a
winter Oh a winter breakdown of sorts
obviously as it relates to this summer
I don't know again like I feel like the
art takes place in the head the audience
members so it's it's as you see it and
and I for me what was if there was
something specifically to capture in
that whole sequence it was just uh you
know it leo comes in with a with a more
positive energy that we've seen and
there's the latkes and and his
headphones and dances a little bit it
was just important to capture that
feeling of love lost over the summer and
and maybe feeling of Elia they didn't
pursue it as quickly as he should have
or that maybe he's had four months he
hasn't thought about Oliver as often and
he gets this phone call and it's like
wow that summer was so amazing and I
will never share that connection with
anybody again
and as you see it in the fireplace or
the secret before that that's however
you see it is right and I I wouldn't
know what the right answer is just that
lady there and then
let's go to this yeah a question for
Timothy when I came out of the cinema
with my friend I think we were both sort
of speechless for a good ten minutes
after seeing the film and I just
wondered what your initial reaction was
when you saw the complete film and
whether at that moment they kind of
thought it might become bigger than
you'd all expected or whether that kind
of happened a lot later yeah well so you
know I went to school in the fall
semester after we shot the movie over
the summer and right after I finished
shooting Lady Bird actually and the
advice I got was to watch it before
Sundance cuz I wasn't gonna be able to
watch like I wouldn't be able to fully
appreciate it but I wanted to like see
it in a beautiful people for the first
time so I guess the answer is just all
very weird because first time I watched
it was it was like it was like a
thousand people there so I couldn't
really watch it because I was like man
I'm sitting here with a thousand people
and I'm having sex with a PG great and
but then but and then when it ended I
don't know like Armie Hammer who
obviously plays Oliver he had been in
Birth of a Nation the year before at
Sundance and the way he had described
the reaction when that movie ended he
said was like in 11 minutes there people
were going were enthusiastic about it
and then after her coming ready I'm
finished it was more like stunned in the
eye and I couldn't read it and I know
what it was I remember army and I like
saunter backstage and there was this
there's like a photo booth and like we
like awkwardly took photos and then just
waited and to see what reactions were
gonna be but it was a weird I didn't I
didn't I couldn't see it the first time
and and also it was like freezing out it
was like a there was a big snowstorm and
they were watching this movie that was
took place in Italy over the summer and
and it was such an immersive experience
it was like being right back there so we
had the first time I thought it was
weird but you know in the 73 times I've
seen it since like yes there's just okay
what was it like for you Daniel the
first time you'd seen get out where and
who did you see it where I small in a
laptop
that's what a laptop yeah before a
reshoot so I didn't have an ending so
because he had to recreate what we did
and then it was iuck not really sad I
think that's the film messed me up like
because the client like that descent
into rage that that's Joe it's like so
yeah it was kind of like sad and in the
end note because it was still did the
police at the end the police and he gets
arrested so I was at our mind like and
then I watched it in an LA and I just
couldn't really watch it properly I
think it would been great it all been
like all posted finish and I just those
those screeners are so overwhelming that
you kleiner can't really watch the film
properly because you just it's just too
much and then there's a bit with the the
bingo seem and Matt Bradley Whitford in
the bingo scene that's when I kind of
kind of relax there was a TARDIS I
really like this film as I like it I
mean it was like I like it doesn't and
then then my friends are there and my
family is there God do you like it too
and then there's some said yeah so that
was it and then I kind of just and I
miss out there it's not love to know
what your parents kind of think at the
moment or both of you kind of you know
with the success and the nominations you
know they keeping you well and really
grounded or you know they just as
thrilled for you as everyone else
yeah that's both I mean okay we've got
one last question and lady's got the
microphone just here hi I'm Owen I just
again I really want to thank both of you
guys for these amazing movies I
requested for Timothy because now you're
really working on your craft in front of
the camera have you ever considered
potentially doubling in like writing or
directing behind the camera yeah
absolutely absolutely and uh he was a
writer director named Xavier Dolan that
I'm a huge fan of because there's a
maze-like he's I guess he's 28 now but
you know he made a movie called I killed
my mother and I was night
he's 19 or 20 and I mean he's made like
a number of little girls and mommy's
excellent and Laurance anyways so when I
see him doing it that's very inspiring
but now I would be very patient and I
feel like you know all the universes
told me at this point is your good actor
so I got it you know that's the only
thing I'm trepidatious about going
through all this stuff for the young age
is this feeling of like hey I want to be
back I don't want to be like oh yeah
like you know he's a great young actor
and now you know so and I also want to
make sure it's not kind of like Lady
Bird you know the great the great thing
about Lady Bird was wasn't you know an
actor directing a movie was like
three-minute takes that are you know
better unspecific and just feel like
life filmed it was like I'm the writer
director and this is Jorah get out too
like this is exactly how I want it to be
done so if I ever did it that would be
the interest not to you know capture a
tone vaguely and and get the experience
being a director that that wouldn't be
fair I just want to say I can't wait to
see whatever comes next for both of you
and congratulations on the nomination
success the success of both the films
thank you Tim Thank You Daniel clear
[Applause]
[Music]